[Musique]
bonsoir colas laier merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france on a
beaucoup commenté parce qu'ils seraient
le fait office de modèle de premier de
la classe partout dans le monde pour
avoir vacciné plus de 20% de sa
population alors des millions de doses
avant tout le monde et le ministère de
la santé qui a donné un début
d'explication avec cet échange si je
puis dire de donner comment réagit la
population israélienne
la plupart des israéliens sont en faveur
de la vaccination
les deux communautés qui pourrait-il
être opposées sont ils à la communauté
arabe qui représentent 20% de la
population du rempart et les ultra
orthodoxes et commentés ultra
religieuses qui sont assez réticents
elles ce sont ces deux communautés qui
ont eu le taux de contamination les plus
élevés mais la plupart des israéliens
soutiennent le programme de vaccination
et font confiance au gouvernement croit
que conformément à sa promesse est d'ici
à fin mars
tous les citoyens de plus de 16 ans
auront été vaccinés cela fait israël le
premier pays à avoir vacciné la majorité
de sa population
paul asselin ont parlé dans de cet
échange a donné contre vaccin si j'ose
dire ça ne pose pas un problème de
respect de la vie privée
en israël personne ne trouve à redire
finalement sur cette question des
changes de données certains israéliens
ont fait part de leurs inquiétudes
effectivement un désenclaver des
questions étiquettes et violation de la
vie privée et dans le même temps cela
crée une division entre les pays riches
comme israël qui peuvent se permettre de
mettre en place un tel programme de
vaccination et des pays plus pauvres ou
aux revenus moyens
le israël notamment le gouvernement
montre bien que s'agissant de vie privée
ce qui est partagé ce qui est échangé
n'est pas une information personnalisée
il s'agit d'informations générales
telles que par exemple le nombre de
personnes vaccinées
le nombre de personnes décédées le
nombre de personnes qui ont contracté
une forme grave de la maladie
il étudie également la façon dont le
vaccin fonctionne il suivait l'évolution
de l'épidémie au cours du temps et les
différents taux de vaccination la
plupart des israéliens l'acceptent mais
bien sûr certaines personnes bien qu'il
s'agisse d'une minorité ont soulevé des
interrogations
alors justement pour la flyer
cet échange de données ça peut servir
comme vous l'avez bien expliqué avoir
une forme de retour sur expérience bien
utile un pour le reste de la planète
concernant l'efficacité de ce vaccin est
ce que on a déjà juste eu mans un retour
d'expérience sur les premiers vaccins
qui ont été injectés aux israéliens il
ya eu quelques informations je crois
aujourd'hui en ce sens sur l'efficacité
justement les autorités israéliennes ont
été surprise par la réaction suite au
premier vaccin
d'après les experts ne s'attendaient pas
à ce qu'une seule dose du vaccin serait
plus efficace c'est qu'elle ne l'était
il faut recevoir deux injections pour
être parfaitement protégé mais il
semblerait que les anticorps augmente de
6 à 12% après la seconde injection
il faut savoir que des milliers
d'israéliens sont tombés malades après
avoir reçu le vaccin mais seulement la
première injection et le nombre
d'anticorps n'était pas suffisant pour
lutter contre la coved après une seule
injection
ce qui explique la situation isralienne
sa particularité c'est que notre pays
est relativement coty la population
n'est que de 9 millions de personnes
israël a donc pu mobiliser tous ses
efforts tout sa recherche afin à
d'immuniser majorité du pays
le système de santé israélien est
également numérisé donc les citoyens
recevait des informations par sms leur
disant de se rendre dans leur centre
médicaux locaux afin de se faire
vacciner donc tout cela est numérisé et
toutes les informations sanitaires des
israéliens sont disponibles sous forme
numérisée depuis plusieurs décennies la
distribution du vaccin a été également
menées de manière logistique qui a pas
mais ce qui a aidé au déploiement de ce
programme alors une décision ce soir
communiqués par le gouvernement
israélien qui a décidé de prolonger
jusqu'à fin janvier
les mesures de confinement et d'exiger
des tests négatifs kobe 19 pour entrer
dans le pays et ce malgré la vaccination
qu'est ce que ça dit finalement qui est
quand même une grande prudence sur
l'efficacité de cette vaccination que le
vaccin ne fait pas tout le gouvernement
effectivement est très prudent il s'agit
de notre troisième confinement en israël
et cela a commencé il ya une semaine et
demie et étaient censés se finir ce
vendredi le gouvernement a déclaré qu'il
le prolongerait pour dix jours
supplémentaires
on pense que le gouvernement ne pourrait
plus le prolonger au delà car un quart
de la population a perdu son emploi
beaucoup de commerces sont fermés les
restaurants ne propose que des
livraisons
il y a beaucoup de colère concernant
cette fermeture de l'économie et
beaucoup d'inquiétudes quant à la
relance de cette économie
le gouvernement est très préoccupée par
le variant du coronavirus celui qui
vient du régime également d'afrique du
sud
donc il faut effectivement avoir des
autorisations spéciales pour entrer en
israël
et ces personnes doit avec se soumettre
un peuple qui seulement de 10 à 15 ans
des hôtels d'isolation ont été mis en
place pour les étrangers donc il passe
deux semaines à temps ses hôtels le
gouvernement ne risque rien il ya
également une dimension politique
au programme de vaccination en mars des
élections ont lieu et le premier
ministre israélien benjamin netanyahu
espère pouvoir
se servir de ce succès vaccinale est que
cela allait de rats à être réélu que
cela va renforcer sa popularité d'ici à
deux mois
merci beaucoup pour la flyer j'en ai les
secours rt internationale de nous avoir
explosé cette situation de la stratégie
vaccinale dans l'état hébreu